big win for religious liberty yesterday
at the supreme court the court ruled six
to three in kennedy versus bremerton
school district that the school violated
coach joseph kennedy's rights when it
fired him for kneeling and saying a
private prayer after football games
the biggest takeaway is that religious
freedom is not completely dead in
america
but the second biggest takeaway
and this has been underreported
is that liberals have absolutely no idea
what conservatives actually believe
instantly after the decision came out a
bunch of prominent libs on social media
jumped at what they thought was going to
be conservative hypocrisy you saw a
million variations of well if you think
conservatives should be allowed to pray
privately at school then you probably
think that jews and muslims should be
allowed to do that too right
gotcha
to which all of the conservatives
replied
uh-huh yup sounds good
it wasn't wasn't the first time that
we've seen this kind of thing
we were seeing this liberal disconnect
for weeks after the carson decision from
the supreme court if you think
christian students in maine should be
able to spend their education funding at
christian schools then maybe jews and
muslims should be allowed to spend it at
their own schools huh
huh
uh-huh yeah that's great sounds like a
great idea let's do it
after the dobbs decision you want to ban
abortion huh well maybe we should pass a
law to make men
support the women that they impregnate
what do you think about that
i think that's a great idea where do i
sign up for that i cool let's go let me
co-sponsor that you you don't like gay
marriage huh well if you're such a
defender of marriage what if we made it
harder for straight couples to get
divorced
awesome
right you support the second amendment
huh so uh you think it's fine for black
men to own guns
i do yes
one in four black men in america already
own guns and black rifles and black
people they're both great in my book
the list goes on
and on
it is a huge political weakness for the
libs i think it probably explains in
part why conservatives have been making
such unusual gains in recent years
if you want to defeat your opponent the
first thing that you've got to do is try
to understand your opponent
right now the conservatives generally
understand what motivates the libs
and the libs don't have even the
foggiest notion of what motivates us
it's not even just the radical libs who
have no idea what conservatives believe
it's even the
squishy conservatives the center left
the former conservatives david frum
david frum who is a speechwriter during
the bush administration he was a vaguely
kind of conservative guy and now he's a
sort of center liberal guy he tweeted
out
after the the kennedy case after the
case
that
uh vindicated the football coach for
praying privately after the football
games he said
supreme court opens way for rousing
chants of allahu akbar before high
school sporting events
haha
you conservatives you're gonna because
david frum's idea here is that the
conservatives while they're celebrating
the christian being able to pray
privately after the football games the
chris the conservatives hate muslims and
so if the muslims pray we're we're
really going to hate that right which to
me is
not only
false it not only rings false it rings
extremely dated though i suppose it
makes sense coming from from because
from came to prominence during the bush
years and during the bush years it was
at least commonly believed that the
muslims they're our real enemy the
radical islamic extremists they're the
real threat to civilization i suspect
today it feels a little bit different
doesn't it
which group do you think poses a greater
threat to your way of life and to your
kids and to your rights into your
country do you think it's the muslims or
do you think it's the radical leftists
i got to tell you these days if i'm
saying what's the most immediate threat
look
islam
the muslim groups have been invading the
west since the 7th century so i'm not
saying there's no threat there battle of
lepanto battle of vienna battle of
poitiers there listen this is a
long-standing tradition okay but today
right now in the year of our lord 2022
what poses the greatest threat to me
islam or radical leftism it's radical
leftism no question about that we're
talking about schools i would much
sooner send my child to a madrasa then i
would send him to most woke public
schools because
whatever differences i have with the
muslims on matters of theology
philosophy and the like
at least the muslims aren't going to try
to convince my son he's a little girl
okay
what whatever
disagreements i have with the islamic
world
frankly the the claims that are made by
radical leftism boys are secretly girls
babies aren't really babies we everyone
who built our civilization is evil
there is no god all the claims of of the
radical left are way more dangerous than
what whatever whatever claims are being
made by the muslim world
but people don't quite get that
people don't quite they they really
believe someone like david frum i guess
or the
the rest of these guys they really
believe that conservatives we just hate
muslims and it's
it's just not true it's just is it is it
true you ask yourself if you are a
conservative if you're a center right
do you is that is that really what you
think the fear is allahu akbar at at
high schools
a muslim or a jew or something making a
private prayer no i think the far
greater risk to our civilization comes
from
atheism business insider i think they've
rebranded just to insider
this is a very far left-wing
news outlet
they're very upset that gen z right now
is going to be having less sex actually
gen z doesn't have a lot of sex they
have very open promiscuous views on sex
but they have less real life actual sex
than previous generations headlines
swearing off men and avoiding intimacy
gen z reconsiders sex in the wake of a
post row world
madeline v might be done with men
altogether a 24 year old marketing
assistant who identifies as bisexual
madeleine who asked that insider only
use her first name has decided that
sticking to female partners may be the
safest sexual root these days it's not a
fear of men exactly that has inspired
this young woman to consider swearing
off an entire gender it's the heightened
fear of unwanted pregnancy and a
subsequent lack of options that has
forced madeline to proceed with sexual
caution in the wake of friday's supreme
court decision gutting federal abortion
rights protections
right so so insider this left-wing
outlet is is writing this
as though this should be horrifying to
everybody
it's just like those people at the top
of the show
here and this is it's not that she fears
and hates men
it's that she doesn't she doesn't want
to have an unwanted pregnancy if she's
not allowed to kill her child so now
she's going to be a little more sexually
cautious
great
good good good that's sort of the point
that's good for the baby obviously the
baby who will not be killed through
abortion
but it's good it's good for society that
we won't have this sexual chaos
everywhere but it's good for madeleine
it's good for madeleine too
does anybody still seriously believe
years after me too years after
the the
enough is enough movement
does anyone seriously believe that
hookup culture is really really good for
women the article goes on
i wish i could read the entire article
for you they say
quoting quoting a young woman
surprisingly enough i've actually had
dreams where i'm pregnant and i can't
find a way to take care of myself
adeline said correcting herself saying
the visions were more akin to nightmares
she can't find a way to take care of
herself
what about a um
a husband
have you thought if you become pregnant
it's probably not going to happen
because you know you sit on a toilet
seat if you become pregnant it's going
to happen because you have sex with
somebody what if hear me out i know this
is crazy what if you do
what
everyone did throughout all of human
history until about 40 years ago and
marry that person and then you don't you
don't need to worry about just taking
care of yourself you will have a husband
who will go out and make money for you
and provide food and shelter for you and
you can raise the family and you can you
can do some work yourself as well but
you won't have to carry that whole
whole heavy load yourself you'll have
what something that's called a family
so family this is an old-fashioned
concept it existed
well as recently as i don't know a
couple decades ago but a family is when
people come together in something called
a marriage and a marriage i know we've
we've changed all the definitions and we
nothing means anything anymore but a
marriage is when a man and a woman come
together and they love each other
ideally and then they produce a child
like you're saying you know
well that part would have come first but
whatever that's okay and you come
together and then you live together and
you can even make more children and you
can have a good life if you want or or
you can just continue to live alone in a
sort of miserable isolated alienated
existence working for some other guy at
a company another guy who doesn't care
about you and will throw you under the
bus the second that you're no longer
profitable to him and you instead of
sleeping with
a hundred different men none of whom
care about you at all
you can just sleep with your husband and
instead of killing your own children you
can actually give birth to them and
raise them and have a loving wonderful
existence
i know it's radical and crazy i'm not
i'm being obviously somewhat somewhat
humorous here in the way i'm describing
it but i actually think people probably
do need to hear it i actually think that
the younger generations who have been
raised in the madness of the sexual
revolution and in the wake of the sexual
revolution probably don't think about
these things all that much because the
hookup culture is just
it's just ubiquitous it's just the way
that things are
the idea of getting married young and
staying married and having kids and
having a good life it's it's a foreign
concept
frankly it was it was
a somewhat foreign concept even when i
was a teenager growing up in liberal
places i can't even imagine now
ever since the draft decision was leaked
adeline has had to entirely rethink
whether or not she wants to start having
sex telling insider that she's terrified
to make a choice that could leave her
with an unwanted child good catherine
said
she's been left to reevaluate the
consequences of casual sex that have
suddenly become very real
awesome great she says as much as i want
to have fun in my 20s what happens to me
when the fun stops what happens to me
when i might be in need of an abortion
and can't access that
what happens when the fun stops great
question to ask yourself
in hookup culture if you're just hooking
up you don't just bring up that stuff
right away normally
she said but when it comes to if you're
actually going to sleep with someone i
think at this point that definitely
needs to be addressed
this is really great stuff
the hookup culture is terrible for
everyone it's very enticing it's very
tempting i know it seems fun at the time
but ultimately it's not fun and it makes
everybody miserable
it's also probably the primary driver of
the rape culture
hysteria that was going on in recent
years and the metoo movement and all of
that none of that would have been
possible without a culture that
encouraged promiscuous sex obviously
rape would still happen but the idea of
a rape culture this pervasive endemic
sort of men exploiting women and
pressuring women and harvey weinstein
saying come on up to my hotel suite and
these drunken rendezvous that occur all
over colleges and bars where consent is
very unclear and and the lines that
people want to to engage in their their
blurred lines
none of that would be possible without
the sexual revolution and a culture of
promiscuous sex
and the consequences of that have been
disastrous especially for women but the
main reason i want to bring up this
article
is not even all of that it's to remind
conservatives of a very important truth
namely
culture
very often is downstream of politics you
know andrew breitbart had that famous
line politics is downstream of culture
which is true in as much as the movies
matter and the press matters and books
matter and
private civic associations matter yeah
that's all true
but politics is downstream of culture is
a slogan and like all slogans it cannot
convey the
whole of reality
and if it's if
politics is downstream of culture is
taken to its extreme it's nothing more
than an excuse for conservatives and
libertarians to ignore
the political order and actual
government
and the power that the people happily
give us on occasion
culture can be downstream of politics
too
the example that i frequently use is
east and west germany
the german east germany was was
conquered by the soviet union for the
latter half of the 20th century west
germany remained
free remained part of the west
west germany
has very high rates of people who
believe in god today east germany is
almost entirely atheist
why is that is that because of regional
variations in rot wurst and bavarian
donuts
no
it's because east germany was dominated
by an officially atheist regime for 40
years
that's why
these these women are showing you this
right now they're saying gosh you know
when the law was a certain way
i i engaged in this kind of behavior in
my private life but now that the law is
different i'm going to i'm going to
behave in a different way this is
something that we have known throughout
all of history and that somehow
conservatives and libertarians forgot
for the last 30 or 40 years but the law
is a teacher
the law shapes society
conservatives and libertarians
especially are so good at understanding
incentives but we we seem to forget that
when it comes to the law
when you create legal incentives
for certain behaviors you get more of
them when you create legal disincentives
for certain behaviors you get less of
them the incentives and disincentives
created by dobbs
are absolutely magnificent and we should
double down on it
have much more pro-life legislation
throughout the states it will not only
be good for the babies though it
obviously will be it will be good for
everyone involved
if you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show make sure that you
check out the rest on apple podcast
spotify wherever you listen to podcasts
and most importantly of all
because we need your support become a
daily wire member go to dailywire.com
knowles access an entire library of
exclusive content and use code knowles
for 25
off your new membership today
dailywire.com
knowles code knowles what's my name
knowles see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you